yeah well uh speaking of uh of specials
speaking of being special yeah real
quick somebody did we'll play this first
and then we'll get into these couple
videos i want to play
uh this is a gringo poppy deleted scene
you want to see it not really but we are
going to okay
yo
what's up what's up what's up
hold on frozen is that you
no it's not me
you guys ever heard of fajitas
it's just opening with you guys ever
heard of fajitas
who is this guy so give credit
cat 1000 faces only has 30 subs let's
change that this guy's [ __ ] hold on
we're gonna change that already he's
already won me over
uh here let's uh
i'm subbing here all right here we go
that one knows what i'm talking about
yeah
wait it's his source material
what is this hold on i'm trying to
figure this out because i want to make
sure i'm plugging the right guy here
source material
you know my favorite food is fajitas
oh no this guy's got some stuff uh-oh
wow brendan doesn't have a lot of
friends on the internet huh hold on let
okay we're gonna get into this but let's
finish this first
yo
dallas
what's up dallas what's up what's up
you guys ever heard of fajitas whoever's
doing this by the way is also a dude
perfect to play because he's in good
shape because the guy's in good shape so
he kind of looks like brennan a little
bit pretty funny the face especially
that's oh that's that's not his real
face
oh that's that's a
an authentic brenden shop mask
this guy this guy knows what i'm talking
about yeah fajitas are popping the the
thing
he looks like carl havoc
tomorrow whatever [ __ ] on me about it is
they come out and they're all like
and people are like what
and i'm like
right here
right here
i went there i went there
yeah you know i make it rain tortillas
too oh
i am already saying this whoever that is
100 is on that fighter in the kids
subreddit of course this is 100 somebody
that's on that subreddit or or
at least pays very close attention to it
because it's all the brandon stuff
rolled into one clip and by the way by
the looks of it you can't be like oh
you're just a fat guy who doesn't crush
puss this is a good looking guy and he's
pretty [ __ ] funny he's very funny
it's funnier with the knees lap right
right they did it again
i love this
that was the end of that video i posted
the link in the chat for everybody
um
oh [ __ ] so hold on this i don't know
what this is just you know my favorite
food is fajitas i love fajitas do you
like fajitas
you ever get those yeah you do right
next words because it's more than a meal
it's very exciting
when you order a fajita you order them
and then a couple minutes later they
bring them out
and it is loud i want that same feeling
i go to chili's in order fajitas
you know what i'm talking about
smoke it's like 4th of july
everyone's like oh my god and this is an
old nick schwarzen because he doesn't
have the coke below yet
god
what is no prove me wrong and a little
bit of that yeah
what the [ __ ] is that
those for you to set the floors off
you're going to steal a nick
schwartzenberg
and you're using a fajitas line that by
the way that wasn't even from tv that
was just him at the laugh that was him
working on material you're right that
was him just working on material
oh you're right that makes it even worse
maybe his maybe his thought process is
like well if you
did the bit and you didn't decided to
throw the bit out because then i can
have it right like maybe that's his
thought process yeah
it's brendan schwab's the joke vulture
picking up [ __ ] dead shitty bits off
the ground yeah that's what i mean he's
just going through the garbage at the
comedy store looking for notepads you're
right like a little raccoon in the car
just pulling out the shitty jokes
godzilla get out of here brenden he
stands outside
and he's looking over and he waits for
he waits for like kurt metzer to crunch
crumble pickle now and throw it in the
garbage and he he runs up and he just
grabs and he runs away with the papers
[Laughter]
don't you hate [ __ ] civilians [ __ ]
civilians
then it turns into an arts and crafts
project
another level of excitement
tortillas you have all these little sour
cream guac
tortillas
it's not great
brandon brendan come on come on dude
oh this is okay this was you showed me
two seconds
this is i gotta say personally for me
this this video kind of triggers me okay
this one's a little bit it's probably a
few months old this is before brian
callan came back and they were doing the
fighter and the kid with two kids with
the two black guys and like a [ __ ] oh
wait no no no no no this that's a
different video that i'm thinking of
this is god there's so many brandon
videos
guys so many brendan vanessa that's what
i'm thinking of is next yeah yeah okay
so here you go it just comes to
territory yeah i told these guys all the
time dude social media is not real man
that's not the real world people have
polarizing comments on there and they're
trying to get attention so they post the
most wild [ __ ] i see any of those people
in the street oh let me get a picture
man let me do this yeah yeah um the
thick boy merch oh it sucks yeah i sell
out every time and you have it on oh you
sold that a long time ago
went from from finding the stand up i
i've never bought thick boy merchandise
no i don't even know how that happens
why is this black guy wearing an oasis
shirt because the podcast
oh i've always wanted to do stand
stand-up where do we get to the part
where these black guys hit that chinese
person for no reason and take his money
oh that's him with the directions for
the store steal his bicycle yeah into it
was meeting brian caligan and then doing
pot of comedy podcasts it's pronounced
rickshaw oh you're right yeah it's
you're right
brian would do hang on i'm trying to
learn about the calm day podcast call me
podcasters are my favorite kind of
podcast in my opinion firing the kids
but it wasn't a live podcast suck dude
brian's doing now but whatever um
why do live podcasts why do they suck
live podcaster oh i get it because
they're hard you know why live podcasts
are edited and funny you know why live
podcasts are hard because yeah exactly
you can't do five takes and put it
together you kind of gotta just do it
don't you it's not easy but it can't be
done
i know a couple guys
is there a lot of pressure i mean even
for all you guys like for example uh
because you why why is brandon dressed
like he's about to train rocky what's up
with that hat you've been put on by joe
rogan you're a murderer rock a lot of
these great comics right yeah i'm going
to have you eating lightning and crap in
nix watson's jokes
you're a killer rock a comedy killer
i'll have you eating d-ball and [ __ ]
next words
[Laughter]
and like i said like i i know of your
work i know what you do look how
masculine he is in this though he's
pretty masculine he's masking for sure
yeah so is there a lot of pressure for
asking his lack of talent
to do better than what people expect out
of you because a lot of people feel that
you've been kind of put on a platform
because a lot of people have pushed you
up there to be at a certain place
actually this guy is asking what we're
wanting to ask for a while but he's
asking him nicely because i feel like
that's a lot of pressure right i don't
feel the pressure i feel like you're too
stupid to understand it a baby doesn't
[ __ ] worry about dying it's a baby
because you're too stupid and because
all you care about is money and getting
your dick sucked in your truck right and
as long as those two needs it's a nice
truck
i did see a raptor the other day
and it is
i don't like anyone who drives them i'm
like you're a [ __ ] but the truck isn't
nice the truck's pretty cool i would
never be caught dead in one because it's
like how small is your dick right but a
raptor is a pretty cool truck like uh
so rogan galea bryan theo uh joey tatino
bobby lee
cummings the entire list of these
monster comics they're not going to
cosign if i wasn't funny
so you're making them cos like why do
they have to cosign they're not going to
cosign if you're not funny well let me
tell you something as we found out
people many are many many of them have
co-signed on you
because you're not funny brendan i'm not
going to sell every show on the road
multiple times in multiple cities year
after year if i wasn't funny yeah
no you could just be famous yeah you
know you know who else sells out shows
everywhere he goes and he's not a comic
mick foley but he goes to comedy clubs
and tells wrestling stories stevo same
thing stevo's really not that funny yeah
but he's likable and he's famous
so again that online chatter is not real
dude it's not really about what happens
if it's not real why did you like
sick two investigators on bobby lee yeah
why did you hire black cube to follow
bobby lee around and try to discredit
him like he was one of harvey
weinstein's rape victims
on the stage in the crowd
again ticket sales podcast views you
know bank account that's all real oh the
bank account huh hey i got more money
than you you [ __ ] yeah nickelback has
more money than me too but they [ __ ]
suck like nickelback still sucks far
less than brendan shaw that's a good
point yeah and they're funnier mm-hmm
i i can see that in black rather
than [ __ ] brendan schwab you know
what i'd agree because this would be
like two or three songs and you'd be
like i know those songs remember that
song know it was a good one remember
that's yeah oh yeah remember i remember
fingering your girl listen to that song
and like everyone look everyone's had
their finger in a [ __ ] to a [ __ ]
nickelback song at some point you know
there's something to remember
i've never had my finger in some chicks
[ __ ] while brendan shaw was talking
about fajitas
and he might have had his finger in
bobby elise girl's [ __ ] but i don't
[ __ ] know about that
about anything else i feel no pressure
because dumb people never feel pressure
yeah that's why quarterbacks are so good
at their job
quarterbacks are [ __ ] you think tom
brady is a brilliant guy
do you think tom brady would be a guy
that you could sit down and discuss
philosophy and ancient literature with
no he's a pretty dumb guy but he's like
he works hard he eats right and he's
like football he's like quarterbacks
only need to be smart enough to learn
all the plays
you know what it feels like you don't
feel any pressure forrest gump
hey you know why all the [ __ ] well
all the top guys like not the top brass
but the top grunts in the military like
the chris kyles and all these great
snipers and these [ __ ] grunts in the
marine corps are so [ __ ] cool in
combat because they're kind of dumb
there i am
i feel no pressure you have a very
strong mentality why do you know do you
not feel that you would you you would
have to what else am i yeah what am i
gonna do what else would you do that's
true
that you shouldn't be doing it yeah
brendan you know why all these other
neurotic people are actually like
[ __ ]
really funny people because they're
neurotic and they hate themselves yeah
and because they spend every waking
moment of every day fighting the
existential dread and self-loathing
and they have to be it literally becomes
a coping mechanism
for all the actual misery that's inside
of you so you're constantly in your head
coming up with jokes even even just to
pop yourself
just to [ __ ] just to keep yourself
from going you know what i could just
jump off the spout yeah that'd be fine
too
when are we gonna listen to them yeah
yeah yeah
if they knew what they were doing they
would brendan here's the problem buddy
it's i don't think anybody suggests you
to list them you should you could ignore
your haters no one's telling you not to
the promise is you're actively suing
them
do you see the difference brennan do you
see the difference between going like
i'm going to ignore these haters so i'm
going to actively sue them sans ceilings
in the chat has a great point he says
shav is a hot chick who wants to be more
than a hot chick
that's what he is that's personality
wise what he is he's the like when you
see these hot chicks that are like i
want to get into podcasting or write a
book and you're like you're a hot chick
that's you know what i mean like when
remember when like a porn star is trying
to get into like
we're gonna do like a podcast like
nobody cares what was the one the
original one on that was the one on
playboy network remember the two chicks
would do like the podcast what was that
or it was before podcast but it was you
know what i'm talking about yeah i don't
remember the name of it club or hot club
i didn't listen to it because it was
chicks yeah in front of microphones
so um
mike tyson had francis
naganua or naga work here anymore
uh on his podcast and mike tyson uh mike
tyson then also had brendan schaub on
the same podcast let's see how it goes
what do you say oh no oh like you know
i know you used to work in san francisco
because i don't think we're ready that's
true yeah that's true
because is it fair to say like come on
but then
dude
i'm uncomfortable i'm uncomfortable i'm
uncomfortable he keeps touching him he
keeps touching him not only does he keep
touching him but look at the body
language of the dude he does not like
him he's leaning away from him i
can sympathize with uh francis
neganaganu
because
i'm not a guy who likes to be touched i
think you're kind of the same way yeah
like it's one thing if it's with
somebody you like of course but like
when you're just doing like if people
just keep like um bro yep like right bro
right bro like it's i that's always been
a pet peeve of mine stop touching me you
can
we can convey things to each other
without touching once in a while when
you get really hype and you're like yeah
or like you know you're watching like a
football game and you just came back
from a huge thing you're like oh
yeah but that's
that's it mine is a i do if i if i'll be
like
like the elbow but that's usually
because you're like
hey a lot of times it's because you
can't say something yeah you want to be
like
[Music]
just because when you're ranked number
one
he's now now he's like come on man
look at him he sees it his mood is
man
and he just you know this black guy's
like
the [ __ ] killer is what he is like
he's an mma i cannot get on rogan if
i'm going to be rude to this man so he's
like trying to be like i gotta be this
is the classic example of
the only thing
stopping this dude from saying stop
[ __ ] touching me is joking about the
essence and spirit of joe rogan
because he's a fighter who doesn't if
you're not a comic the next important
thing to be if you're going to go joe
rogan is a fighter that's a big [ __ ]
deal you know
and also you don't want to piss off the
guy that's going to commentate your
fight and interview afterwards either so
you're like
i'm sure you don't pay attention to this
but they have john or they have john as
the for the first time his career as an
underdog
they have you as the favorite
which is
stop
is this making anybody else really
uncomfortable i am uncomfortable
it's making me itchy
it's a little surprising i think it'd be
like maybe even money or maybe maybe you
but it's like i think if he touches his
leg
i mean leaving i have you as like uh
that's that this this guy is [ __ ] up
by the way don't follow mma enough to
know these dudes like religiously
but this guy's a [ __ ] animal like
he's a [ __ ] like they're just his arms
oh yeah i'm obviously a heavyweight
right because like the heavyweight guys
are always the most terrifying mma guys
and that guy looks like
that guy looks like one of those dudes
that mma like you know when he's gone
three
he's 20.
in the heavyweight division
jesus christ he's ranked number five in
the ufc's men pound for pound rankings
he's one of those guys that like they
write articles about where some drunk at
a bar was like oh yeah you think you're
so [ __ ] tough and they start pushing
on him and [ __ ] and then it's like you
know witnesses say it was like one punch
and the man was dead he was pronounced
dead on the scene
eight nine is he pinching him now dude
you're not john out we're going sizzler
because when you're ranked number one
it's
just it's
look at his face look at look at this
that is right there and i've seen this
face a million times in my life he looks
like
every bouncer i've ever worked with
that's dealing with a drunk guy and not
even a drunk guy that's getting thrown
out
like a drunk guy that's spending money
and he's being cool
but he keeps like like touching people
like touching like a bouncer and talking
to him and being like yeah man yo yo
it's like yo man yeah right like one
time yo check this out like and you just
see like he looks like that bouncer
dealing with an like a friendly drunk
but where they're like i can't throw
this guy out by his [ __ ] throat
but he needs to stop touching me too
like eventually it's like bro please
stop touching me
it's it's it i feel and how does he not
pick up on social cues
because he sees he's that the cte bro
it's it doesn't
he really i think just doesn't
understand things i think he doesn't
understand how to be a human being i
think that the common sense sector of
his brain got punched out because
anybody could observe very easily like
all right this guy's getting annoyed
travis pick